speaking of significant assets daniel
schneider
more assets out of his pocket because
this report broke today and here's what
happened
there's a league meeting next week and
in advance of the league meeting
information gets sent out to the teams
and in the information sent to the teams
one of the things on the agenda is to
vote
on daniel snyder purchasing
the minority interest in his franchise
from the three gentlemen who have been
trying
for more than a year to sell more than
40 percent of the team
fred smith the chairman and founder of
fedex
robert rothman and dwight shaw
um and what what was going on and i
don't want to get too deep into the
weeds because most people don't care
about this but
the three individuals found a buyer for
their interests
and snyder has a right of first refusal
but he he didn't want to exercise it is
to all three of them just to two of them
and it came down to the fact he didn't
have the money to do it and he couldn't
borrow the money because the nfl has a
limit on how much you can borrow
well the nfl waived the magic wand you
know there's no
there's nothing like having a rule that
you're going to make an exception for to
the point where the rule doesn't matter
they weigh the magic wand they let him
exceed the debt limit and now he can
borrow enough money to buy them out
that's what he's doing at roughly 950
million
for more than 40 percent of the team
that's a valuation of just under 2.4
billion but remember
minority shares aren't worth as much
as the majority ownership because you
don't have voting rights you know the
path to
control of the team but still a
significant transaction
almost a billion dollars that dwight
that daniel snyder has to come up with
to get these guys out of his hair for
good and consolidate shireen 100 of the
team
well and fred smith by the way is
atlanta falcons fan now that's where his
son now is the head coach so
uh move on fred take your money and go
root for your falcons but
you know mike i like the way this
franchise is
is going uh and i know they're under
investigation i understand all that but
i like the hires that they've made since
the investigation started
ron rivera is obviously the face and the
voice of this team martin mayhew
as gm i go way back with martin mayhew
to when he played for the buccaneers i
love
martin mayhew jason wright president
he's shown me a lot of positive things
julie donaldson is senior vp of media so
i like
some of the hires he's made if you can
keep dan snyder out of this team and let
ron rivera and jason wright martin
mayhew and julie
donaldson continue to do what they're
doing now
i think this team has a bright bright
future mike
there is also an implicit conclusion
that can be drawn from the fact that the
nfl
has allowed daniel snyder to exceed the
league's per team debt limit and borrow
the money necessary
to pay for 40 of the team and own all of
it and that
is that it's highly unlikely the end
result of the ongoing investigation into
workplace misconduct will result
in the league requiring daniel snyder to
sell the team remember a few weeks ago
1067 the fan in dc reported that beth
wilkinson
the lawyer that initially was hired by
the team before the league took over the
investigation
had recommended it turns out she hasn't
recommended it yet
someone got their hands on a draft
report where she was recommending
that there be a forced sale of the team
i don't believe that's going to happen i
believe that there will be a significant
fine imposed on daniel snyder i think
we'll find out that the three minority
owners
were fined and money was collected from
them as part of their
exit package of the 950 million that
they'll be getting because
they took snyder to court instead of
handled everything quietly through the
internal arbitration procedures and the
league owners don't like it when the
dirty laundry gets aired
but the the big takeaway for me is that
snyder
will not be forced to sell the team we
won't have another jerry richardson
situation where
jeff bezos or someone else is going to
show up
and buy the franchise from daniel
schneider who's squeezed by
the power structure in the league to
move on as
the discipline for this this problem
however extensive it was however long it
lasted i hope we're going to have
transparency i hope we'll be able to
judge whether or not whatever the
punishment is
fits whatever the crimes are i hope it
doesn't get brushed under the rug
but whatever the end result is it looks
like the nfl is not
going to force him to walk away sheree
yeah that's what this seems to be an
indication of
mike and you know i hope they they solve
the problem that they have and they make
you know whatever suggestions are made
or
or maybe they won't even be suggestions
maybe they'll be forced to make changes
but whatever those changes are they
certainly need to make them based on
what we've
read and heard that that's come out of
this already but i'm with you i hope
there's some transparency and we can see
exactly if if the punishment fits that
crime mike
and uh it's my understanding that snyder
is intent on keeping the team because he
wants his children
eventually to inherit it and run it and
that's why he wants to hang on to it
this is a team he's had for 22
years now bought it in 1999 for 750
million
and now buying 40 percent of the
interest in the team for 950 million it
shows you how the value of these
franchises
continues to go up and up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports